- Get it out! Yes.
Anyway, say hi to Lily.
(women laugh)
I heard that you know
where my parking spot is,
by the way.
- Okay. You know,
I didn't wanna talk about this,
because I didn't know if I am
subjected to legal trouble,
but we filmed the show like
literally across the street.
- Yeah.
- Like on the same lot
and I saw on your Instagram
that you were in New York.
- Oh, we shot our show in New York.
- And so, you're a lot more,
obviously, so much more
famous than I am ever
and so I don't get as nice
of a parking spot as you.
I have to park quite far.
So, like when you weren't here,
I just kinda like slid in.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- And I believe...
- Here's the thing.
- No, this is not a joke.
- I wasn't using it.
- For an entire episode,
I think I parked in your parking spot.
- Here's the thing, we were all gone.
All three of those
people that park there...
- And it was tracking you
and I was telling my A.D.s
and they were like,
I don't know, Josie,
and I was like, I swear to God,
Kelly's still in New York.
I just saw on her Instagram.
She interviewed Seth Meyers.
I literally was tracking you.
- Oh my God,
you're welcome to my spot
when I'm not there.
- Thank you so much.
Don't sue me.